hello to reject nation it's Greg Alva
here with Ashley ed nur that's me
First Lady guest of the year of 2018 you
should be honored
I specifically texted her saying do you
want to be the first lady guest of the
channel of this year and she said I'm so
first female guest of the year Ashley
found out the skin through the Golden
Globe winners of this year but she did
not watch and I did not watch the famous
speech that's going around everywhere
apparently from Oprah Winfrey everyone's
talking about the Cecil B deMille Award
no idea what she talks about Oprah style
and today's page from the day shout-out
because she requested it she's one of
our top pledges is Rosa para beautiful
mother beautiful lady who's going to
school works a full-time job is a
full-time parent and she's also one of
our top pledges on patreon she's lady
Stark of our channel so love you Rosa
you're kind of like our Oprah yes that's
right so it makes it we are moved by you
I believe she gives everybody a car you
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you're ready to cry
[Applause]
talk to the woman and him
[Applause]
cuz she was like who's over in 1964 I
was a little girl sitting on the
linoleum floor of my mother's house in
Milwaukee watching and Bancroft present
the Oscar for Best Actor at the 36th
Academy Awards
she opened the envelope and said five
words that literally made history the
winner is
Sidney Poitier up to the stage came the
Merce Walker elegant man had ever seen I
remember his tie was white and of course
his skin was black and I've never seen a
black man being celebrated like that and
I've tried many many many times to
explain what a moment like that means to
a little girl a kid watching from the
cheap seats
as my mom came through the door bone
tired from cleaning other people's
houses but all I can do is quote and say
that the explanation in Sidney's
performance and lilies of the field amen
amen amen ada in 1982 simply received
the Cecil B deMille Award right here at
the Golden Globes and it is not lost on
me that at this moment there are some
little girls watching as I become the
first black woman to be given the same
award whoo that could have been you
[Laughter]
[Applause]
awesome I didn't realize that and also
with the incredible men and women who've
inspired me who challenged me who
sustained me and made my journey to this
stage possible Denis once and who took a
chance on me for am Chicago Quincy Jones
who saw me on that show and said to
Steven Spielberg yes she is Sophia in
the color purple
Gale who's been the definition of what a
friend is and Stedman who's been my rock
just a few to name I'd like to thank the
Hollywood Foreign Press Association
because we all know that the press is
under siege these days but we also know
that it is the insatiable dedication to
uncovering the absolute truth that keeps
us from turning a blind eye to
corruption and to injustice to to
tyrants and victims and secrets and lies
I want to say that I value the press
more than ever before as we try to
navigate these complicated times which
brings me to this what I know for sure
is that speaking your truth is the most
powerful tool we all have and I'm
especially proud and inspired by all the
women who have felt strong enough and
empowered enough to speak up and share
their personal stories each of us in
this room are celebrated because of the
stories that we tell and this year we
became the story it's one that
transcends any culture geography race
religion politics or workplace so I want
tonight to express gratitude to all the
women who have in do
years of abuse and assault because they
like my mother had children to feed and
bills to pay homes to pursue
[Applause]
they they're the women whose names will
never know
they are domestic workers and farm
workers they are working in factories
and they work in restaurants in there
and academia and engineering and
medicine and science they're part of the
world of tech and politics and business
there are athletes in the Olympics and
there are soldiers in the military and
there's someone else we see Taylor my
name I know and I think you should know
- in 1944 reseat Taylor was a young wife
and a mother she was just walking home
from a church service
she'd attended in Abbeville Alabama when
she was abducted by six armed white men
raped and left blindfolded by the side
of the road coming home from church
she's ready to kill her if she ever told
anyone but her story was reported to be
a double ACP were a young worker by the
name of Rosa Parks on her case and
together they sought justice but justice
wasn't an option in the era of Jim Crow
the men who tried to destroy her were
never persecuted Griese Taylor died 10
days ago just shy of her 98th birthday
she lived as we all have lived too many
years in a culture broken by brutally
powerful men for too long women have not
been heard or believed if they dared to
speak their truth to the power of those
men but their time is up
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's great thanks Beach Oprah she's
like a professional that greasy tailor
died knowing that her truth like the
truth of so many other women who were
tormented in those years and even now
tormented goes marching on it was
somewhere in Rosa Parks's heart almost
eleven years later when she made the
decision to stay seated on that bus in
Montgomery and it's here with every
woman who chooses to say me too and
every young every man who chooses is to
say something about how men and women
really behave to say how we experience
shame how we love and how we rage how we
fail how we retreat persevere and how we
overcome I've interviewed and portrayed
people who had stood some of the ugliest
things life can throw at you but the one
quality all of them seem to share is an
ability to maintain hope for a brighter
morning even during our darkest nights
watching here now to know
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was a beautiful speech right there
yeah it was so well Jesus winged it you
know wow wow that was that was something
special man that was a great speech you
know it's really good I think it's
really special especially because last
year because now we're in 2018 in 2017
opened this floodgate and I feel like
there's still more to come of all these
sexual assault stories all these me two
stories yeah it was really dark time
especially in the entertainment industry
cuz a lot of the stories were coming
from there but it was beyond the
entertainment industry would have
started influencing started noticing a
lot of women in other fields which is
right and women does not involve an
entertainment just like the kind of
workers that she was talking about yeah
exactly all coming out given their meets
you story and it was dark and connective
and so for Oprah to give the speech at
the beginning of the year is inspiring
because now it's like that there's that
she's showing us that there's a huge
light and an awakening coming this is
gonna be a monumental change yeah that's
what was so beautiful and it's Oprah you
know that is really cool that she you
know was the first african-american
woman up there receiving this that's a
great speech and I like that you know
she was talking about the you know
phenomenal men too because you know
there's the guys even seem like they
were all standing and super into it as
well which is cool I wonder how many of
them are gonna get charged with sexual
[Music]
it's sad but that's kind of the weird
world we're in right now it was about
how we're coming in terms of racism and
in sexism all these things of equality
it was just an empowering speech right
now you know it's beyond just exposing
the bad wow she actually brought a huge
sense of light to this and I like how
she hands-on there will be a time when
we're not all saying me too yeah yeah
that's a beautiful thing to say
beautiful and how she said that all the
women that she's portrayed or that she's
interviewed that they all have the one
thing in common which is never get the
exact line sheets and I don't want to
quote her but it was basically about how
like there's you know at the darkest
time there's still like light hopefully
the you know yes day sort of thing which
is really cool horrible times but they
have still a positive outlook now she
was positive in her speech a downer yeah
let's do this
and just I feel inspired she looks great
and she was very like she look great and
her speech was great she got like a
little emotional but it wasn't to read
it was about being strong for the future
yeah yeah that's what was beautiful
about it for Oprah when the Cecil B
deMille Award its speeches like this why
Oprah exactly it's like she did the
Oprah thing it was more than just a
thank-you speech you know wasn't even
really much of a thank-you speech it was
it was a time to give a message yeah and
a time to give hope love you Oprah yeah
and she mentioned Rosa Parks
just like our lovely Rosa Parra I just
feel like everybody was just so like
captivated in like in yeah everybody was
right there you just tell by their faces
they were just really and yeah some
people stood and then later on more
people stood I wish I was in that room
standing next to the rock would you have
been standing from the very sit down she
just started talking oh she's done
moved
you should be proud to be a woman I am
and I'm ashamed to be a man okay yeah
alright guys well thanks for tuning in
you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell to
get notified every time one of our
videos is up you should go check out
Ashley Enders youtube channel you can
follow her on Instagram look at that
pretty face all day or you can watch her
in videos look at her pretty face there
and check out our patreon it's like a
second youtube channel become a patreon
eject today plenty of excuses videos
over there love you guys